Susan Rice was a top national security
official during all eight years of the
Obama administration
she was a US ambassador to the United
Nations then she became the president's
national security adviser in 2013
rice worked with President Obama and
others to shape America's foreign policy
and led the National Security Council
her new book is called tough love great
title
my story of the things worth fighting
for it's published by Simon & Schuster
which by now if you watch this show on a
regular basis you know it's a division
of CBS we hope you watch the show on a
regular basis Susan Rice we are so glad
you're here lucky us and you were here
on the day that the news is so much in
your wheelhouse I promise we'll get to
your book but first we have to start
with the news of the day when you heard
the president yesterday say the China
should investigate the Biden's what did
you think truthfully yes I couldn't
believe it I mean every day we hear
something new that causes you to say did
that really happen this for me was
qualitatively different because because
the President of the United States was
welcoming and inviting our principal
foreign adversary to intervene in our
election again just as he did in 2016
with Russia but here's the difficult
problem with China China is currently
denies that he intervened in the
election but he can't deny he asked
Russia to intervene remember if you had
those emails yes yes right so it's the
same thing he gets on television before
the world and asked China to give him
dirt he tweeted he has the absolute
right to ask other countries to
investigate corruption why is that not
correct well first of all this there's
no evidence of any corruption secondly
what he is saying to China is look we're
in a hot trade war you are doing things
with respect to way and security that
give us great concern but perhaps the
implication is if you manufacture some
dirt that doesn't exist on Biden and
provided to me maybe some of our
problems can go away on the trade front
on the security front that's what's so
dangerous he's in effect saying to our
farmers and our manufacturers and to all
of us who have been
suffering is a consequence of his trade
war that all could be well and perhaps
be resolved on terms more favorable to
China if he gets dirt that was the clear
implication and one other thing if I
might if your China and you're listening
to President Trump on the South Lawn
make that statement what are you
thinking what are you thinking you've
negotiated whether they think this man
is not predictable he's not stable he's
not playing with a full deck and if if
they were being smart and never discount
the Chinese ability to be smart they
think well maybe this is an opportunity
to steal second base whether that's in
trade whether that's in the South China
Sea whether that's in cyberspace we are
projecting insecurity instability and
chaos to the rest of the world so fair
to say you don't think that the
president has a genuinely held belief
that Joe Biden and his son are
potentially corrupt I don't believe he
believes that but even if he did even if
he did what we see consistently out of
this president is that he is putting his
personal political interests above the
national interest with Ukraine he gets
on the phone with a new president of
Ukraine a country that is under
occupation and still in a hot war with
Russia and does no business on behalf of
the United States nothing to protect
Ukraine nothing to uphold the sanctions
it's all about can you help a brother
out what can you do for me and that's
the same with China can we talk about
can we talk about the server surrounding
this phone call and that the fact that
that this the call itself the
information about the call was moved to
a specific server which is considered
separate classified super classified
explain to us what that server is well
most of the business that the National
Security Council does is conducted on a
system which itself is classified to a
very high level there is a separate
system for the most sensitive materials
that are considered compartmented
classified above the top-secret level
and the kinds of things that that
computer system is usually used for do
not relate to phone calls with foreign
leaders they relate to the most
sensitive
that there is which I can't even get
into yeah would have phone call
typically be moving no absolutely not
and in in normal circumstances I can't
even conceive of a conversation that
would get to that level of
classification but say it did then
because of the content of the
conversation it might be moved to a
highly classified system but only if the
content warranted it not because there's
something in there that for political
purposes the White House wanted to hire
because of foreign Lee just because a
foreign leader was involved oh no no no
the foreign leader calls are typically
kept on the normal system and what do
you think about the president attacking
the whistleblower how much how concerned
should that should we be about that and
Mike Pompeo on the call is that normal
that the Secretary of State would be on
the call that the whistleblower in my
experience in the Obama administration I
cannot recall an instance not one where
the Secretary of State was on a
presidential phone call with a foreign
leader typically he would get a readout
later and perhaps get the transcript so
if they do it differently in the trumpet
they say it's not yeah it's not a rule
it's unusual and I gather also that the
National Security Advisor may not have
been on that conversation that would be
highly unusual we learned this morning
that Ukraine is gonna revisit some of
the claims against the Biden's even if
they didn't break the law and there's no
evidence that that they did I do
remember that it was politically awkward
back in 2015 when his son was involved
in the countries he was dealing with
anti-corruption efforts did he
mishandled the situation at the very
least Joe Biden yeah not in my opinion
Joe Biden was doing what he was asked to
do by the President of the United States
consistent with serving our policy
interests our policy interests that we
were were shared with the European Union
and the IMF was to root out corruption
and this prosecutor that he was pushing
on all of our behalf to have removed was
a corrupt prosecutor who was supposed to
go after corruption so the difference
here is very simple President Trump on
the one hand is asking Ukraine for a
favor that benefits him personally and
politically Joe Biden on behalf of
President Obama the United States and
the Western world was asking and pushing
for the removal of somebody who on
behalf of our policy on behalf of
our national interest and that's the
difference and Biden did it
transparently Trump tried to hide it
through sequestering it's the reality we
face Tony and what worries me so much it
gets back to your original point Gail is
for the first time that I can remember
our democracy is under assault our
country is in effect under attack you
write that in the book and that Aleve
that attack is coming now from within
it's coming from 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue and for all the security threats
I saw as National Security Advisor all
the challenges we faced I never thought
I'd see that all right Susan Rice thank
you so much for being with us the book
is tough love we'll be right back stay
with us